let's discuss the latest developments
with texas congressman jeff roy good to
have you back congressman
good to see you shannon okay so
democratic senator chris murphy out of
connecticut said this today he tweeted
republican leaders don't see immigrants
as human
just props to get some laughs and clicks
he said about this bus that arrived in
washington how do you respond
well it's pretty rich coming from
democrats who've been using uh
immigrants as props for their own crash
political purposes while migrants get
abused get put into the sex trafficking
trade why cartels get empowered while
texans get run over that's democrats
whole shtick using immigrants as props
now here you've got governor abbott
trying to bring attention to what's
actually been happening in texas on a
regular basis while democrats like
senator murphy and other democrats
ignore it and governor abbott is trying
to do the job that the president of the
united states and the secretary my orcis
is supposed to be doing and so you know
i'm glad that the governor is bringing
attention to it i'm glad that the
governor is bringing attention to what
we have to deal with by having the
vehicle inspections and causing people
to have to wake up to what happens at
our border but let's just be clear
tomorrow there's still going to be 7 000
or 8 000 people coming across our border
and so the only metric that i'm going to
be grading anybody on how this works out
is whether or not we stop the flow of
traffic at the border and secure our
border for texans and for americans so
that we're not having fentanyl pour into
our schools and having people get abused
and hurt whether they're migrants or
americans
so not surprising there would be
criticism from the left but arguably
also on the right a piece in the
federalist calls out governor abbott
thinking that he could do more it says
he should secure the border he can
actually shut it down abbott's busing
order is quite obviously a stunt a cheap
shot at biden that makes no effective
use of his considerable powers as
governor of texas if abbott were serious
about securing the border he wouldn't
announce a plan to transport migrants to
washington but a plan to take them back
to mexico what do you make of that
criticism
well i mean first of all i want to
repeat the problem right now with the
united states of america and our border
lies squarely to president biden and
secretary my orcis they have a duty to
secure the border and they're failing to
do it americans are getting hurt
migrants are getting hurt our economy is
getting hurt governor rabbits in a tough
spot i applaud what the governor's been
doing with fencing what he's been doing
to try to you know put the the spotlight
on this and dump uh this at the feet of
the of the folks in washington but i do
agree that ultimately we can't allow
this continue and i think that the
governor ought to use article 4 of the
constitution recognize that this is an
invasion and that texas is going to need
to go down to the border and start
turning people away because the
president united states refuses to do
his job and look i know there's some of
these democrats that want to jump aboard
and have these bipartisan approaches to
title 42 but let's be clear we've got a
bipartisan i mean we've got an effort on
the floor right now the house to
discharge a bill that would actually use
title 42 and let's recognize that title
42 the health code laws you know under
the pandemic that's a band-aid on a
gunshot wound we need to right now stand
up and secure the border and actually
turn people away instead of allowing our
country to get inundated so i applaud
the governor for trying to bring a
spotlight on it but i do agree that
texas is going to have to do more given
the complete absence and the willful
abuse and disregard of the
constitutional duties being carried out
by the president and the secretary so
every few days i get something in my
inbox about somebody who's visited the
border a lawmaker from one today senator
says this discussed his concerns about
the administration's plans to lift the
title 42 order and cbp personnel having
to redirect much needed staffing away
from their daily responsibilities of
protecting trade and preventing the flow
of fentanyl and other illicit drugs and
firearms that wasn't from a republican
it came from democrat arizona senator
mark kelly is there enough bipartisan
will to actually do something and and
how bad do you think realistically
things will get when title 42 lifts next
month
well let's just keep in mind that last
year we had 700 000 people released into
the united states but there were 2
million apprehensions that means the
rest of those folks were heavily turned
away under title 42. now whatever
american needs to understand is title 42
is a health code provision there are all
these other uh you know
policies that the current administration
is ignoring like migrant protection
protocols even though they're under a
court order they're allowing the asylum
rules to swallow our border security
right they're allowing asylum to be the
exception that swallows the rule so
that's the actual problem and you know
this shannon because you've been
following it and we're talking about
real problems fentanyl americans dying
ranches getting overrun cartel's in
power and there's a refusal by the
administration to recognize what it's
doing to texas and the american people
democrats recognize it because
politically they're getting crushed
hispanics in texas you saw the polls
today hispanics are not lining up behind
joe biden they've been taken for granted
for a long time and so what we're seeing
now are democrats recognizing they ought
to do something but one last point just
because there's now a rush to do a
bipartisan bill i don't want to hear
more about plans i don't want any more
words i've got republicans lining up
behind microphones alongside democrats
saying oh yeah let's join a bipartisan
bill so they'll present a plan and
they'll say that now the public health
emergency is over so we'll we'll just
say that now title 42 we can be
dispensed with no
let's actually make sure that the
federal government has gotten rid of the
emergency states aren't actually under
an emergency and then we have regular
flow of traffic between mexico and
canada we've got a bill that does that
you bet harold's and we've got a
discharge petition on the floor so i
don't want to hear any more words and
finally i want texas and i want arizona
to stand up and secure our border using
article 4 under the constitution
well congressman keep us updated as we
always talk about these are real human
beings caught in this
taken into trafficking held hostage many
of them die on these journeys too and
we've got to keep those folks in mind
congressman thank you
happy easter
and to you too hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else